اذا هذه الصور
للدمار الذي
لحق بالمطار
جراء الاشتباكات اليوم بين كل من قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني صور اقمار
اصطناعيه التقطتها شركه ماكسير
ونستعرضها الان
لتبيان حجم الدمار الذي لحق في المطار
وطبعا الجسور المؤديه الى المطار ومبنى
القياده العامه الذي تضرر كثيرا وطبعا عدد
من الطائرات دمرت بالكامل كما نشاهد هنا
منها الطائره التابعه للامم المتحده ومنها
طيارات تابعه
لشركات خاصه طبعا ايضا المواجهات ما زالت
مستمره بمحيط المطار
بالمنطقه الشرقيه للمطار حتى الساعه بين
كل من قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
لمحاوله احكام السيطره على هذا المطار
طبعا منذ بد العمليه العسكريه كانت هناك
محاولات للسيطره على ثلاث نقاط استراتيجيه
منها مطار مروي مطار الخرطوم ومطار الابيض
حسم الصراع في مطار مروي لصالح الجيش
السوداني في مطر الخرطوم ما زال مستمر حتى
الساعه وطبعا لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات